je m'appelle pâtit les années de lycée
ont été un vrai cauchemar
tout le monde sait que pat y est et doit
pendant que mes petits camarades et est
sorti et perdaient leur virginité
moi j'étais chez moi à me remplir un
autre trou c'est moi ou ça sent le bacon
chaque jour je me demandais si je
pourrais encore en caissettes
depuis ça m'a frappé et marthe nom ou et
pâtit oui je suis là
[Musique]
à voir la mâchoire costumes avaient fait
perdre davantage que mes vacances d'été
le vilain petit canard devient un joli 6
mois l'ancienne petite grosse je pouvais
être einstein ou sportifs de haut niveau
ou une cause perdue non je crois tu
préfère me venger mais taittinger qu
aucun souvenir qui est incontrôlable
j'aimerais lui écraser la tête sur un
banc je voulais qu'elle souffre comme je
souffrais je voulais encore plus j'étais
insatiable qu'est-ce que vous voulez que
je vous dise
c'était carrément du délire cette
histoire
justement si l'accès
[Musique]